make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the Mighty Avengers yes we
are the blue Marvel versus Schumacher ah
this is kind of a cool little story
right because in the last video we did
on this we had basically talked about
how it tied into the events of infinity
right so like Thanos and his Coll
obsidian which is still like one of the
coolest names here's okay here's my
question for you guys right because I
posted this on Twitter and the reactions
were kind of mixed right people thought
there were other cool names in my mind
the ebony ma is the coolest name ever
for like a comic book villain right just
like the ma or like the ebony ma it's
just an amazing name to have my question
is do you guys agree or disagree Coulomb
city in is the best villainous name ever
created nobody no arguing that point but
in terms of the name the ebony ma do you
guys think that's the best like
villainous name for a character ever or
can you can you think of one better and
if you can post down in the description
I'm curious to see what you guys say but
in the previous video we talked about
how this tied into the events of
infinity and the forces of fan o's the
call obsidian invading Earth for the
purpose of helping Thanos track down
fate right his son now if you guys never
saw the Infinity story or never read the
Infinity story you can check the link
down in the description you guys will
find the whole series there Jonathan
Hickman and all that stuff it's really
really amazing but it's just this
amazingly written series or at least
story arc but ah this is where Doctor
Strange had essentially brought true
McGrath into the main Marvel Universe or
at least began the process of sheer
McGrath invading and that's kind of a
big deal right because she'll McGrath is
kind of like this primordial God right
technically he's was called one of the
many angled ones and the many angled
ones in the way I always explain it I
think is the easiest way to do it if you
imagine a brick wall and you imagine
each one of those bricks is its own
universe right is you know one brick is
the Marvel Cinematic Universe another
brick is the main Marvel Universe and
the story that we're telling right now
and another brick is the real world
where you are watching this video at the
moment the mortar in between those
bricks is where the mini angled ones
reside right that is kind of in this
exceedingly small space and and sure
McGrath is considered one of those
individuals but unlike most of the many
angled ones in fact pretty much all of
them Shue McGrath managed to kind of
break free and then over the course of
time start conquering different
realities across the multiverse right so
he has there's entire universes out
there that have been totally dominated
by Shu McGrath
everything there it's just that like
with dr. strange or the ancient one or
something like that by whatever manner
and whatever means his attempts to
invade this universe have always been
stopped right and that's kind of the
main idea behind his character he's
always trying to show up here now the
truth is that if Shu McGrath in his full
form power and totality
were to arrive in the main Marvel
Universe he would be unstoppable
and that's one of the first things
that's established here right this is
really a facsimile of his character and
we know this from a couple different
ways the first is when blue Marvel
fights him and when I say fights him I
mean like that in the sense that this
version of Shu McGrath is just kind of a
small version of himself that manifests
here on the physical plane and that in
terms of the true form of Shu McGrath
it's out there somewhere in the
multiverse right trying to find a way in
here and in this little version of
itself
it kind of opens a doorway of sorts and
that's all Stephen strange really did
Stephen strange opened up a kind of
doorway which a lot of facsimile of
Schumacher asked to enter and then when
that version of Shu McGrath begins to
basically expand his sphere of influence
across the world then it'll basically
lead to Shu a growth proper invading
into the main Marvel Universe and then
essentially wiping out all the cosmic
entities and all the beings in existence
and then basically conquering everything
right because even characters like
Galactus and eternity and all those
beings would fall before the might of
the vast power of Shu McGrath and the
living tribunals not gonna step in
because it's what she McGrath does right
he's just fulfilling his role if the
Living Tribunal was ever going to step
in he would have done it already in any
one of the other universes that Shu
McGrath conquered but blue Marvel
showing up here and it's really cool the
way all hewing does this blue morals
showing up here is one of these things
where it's kind of like okay so he's
here to save today when it comes to Adam
Brashear this guy's a powerhouse right
this guy is a boss right he's insanely
intelligent he's ridiculously powerful
he's one of the most powerful beings in
Marvel right I mean it's crazy how
capable he is and one of the things we
had talked about is how the staff of
Proxima midnight had basically
quote-unquote disrupted Monica Rambeau
know I'm not really a physicist here and
so when when stuffs being said about how
like you know her photons are turning
into anti photons and eating her alive
or something like that I don't really
understand what that means right oh it
all it really seems like here is her
body's basically just breaking itself
down right essentially the staff has
impacted her in such a way to where her
body's essentially kind of falling apart
is really all it is right and it seems
as though she's kind of losing control
of her powers all that kind of stuff
what Adam Brashear does is he comes
and rectify the situation now this is an
important thing to understand here right
and at first glance it's easy to kind of
overlook and just be like okay so like
there's a thing he basically performs
some kind of power surgery on this girl
if only it were really that simple when
it comes to Monica Rambeau you have to
keep in mind she's called spectrum
because she is essentially the entire
electromagnetic spectrum right that's
what she's made up of she's made up of
every form of light she's made up of all
these different forms of energy that are
out there everything within the aspect
or within the frame of the
electromagnetic spectrum what this means
with atom brashear showing up here is
Ana Bashir is either imbalance with it
or is more powerful than that right so
being able to control or manipulate the
entirety of the electromagnetic spectrum
is no small thing by this one reasons
why we say atom brashear is way beyond a
mega level right because the
electromagnetic spectrum is not confined
simply to earth right it permeates like
the force right it permeates throughout
everything but it permeates throughout
the entirety of the universe
being able to manipulate that lends
credence to the argument which I don't
really buy into fully that atom brashear
is a character that has the potential to
warp reality on a universal scale right
we've never seen him do that there's no
reason to believe that he actually can
there's a kind of argument that's being
made out there that is he's capable of
doing that now the other part of this
and why things get kind of wonky is what
you end up doing is picking up with with
essentially dr. strange of course again
being manipulated by the ebony maw but
dr. strange kind of creating a shield of
sorts a kind of you know impenetrable
force field around the body of Shu
McGrath as it begins to reconstitute
right begins to reconstruct itself and
again that's the kind of power that
we're dealing with here not only that as
Shu McGrath stays in this dimension
longer and longer that portal begins to
open more and more and as that begins to
take place his power becomes stronger
and stronger and this is something to
bear in mind here right this is why Shu
McGrath is so incredibly powerful just
only being in this dimension only being
in this universe for what amounts to
maybe ten minutes he already has the
ability to dominate and control the
minds of everybody in his immediate
space right that's ten minutes of
occupancy within this universe imagine
what he would do with a year right that
that's what we're talking about when it
comes to like Shu McGrath being here
within this exceedingly short amount of
time
he's already able to manipulate and
dominate the Wills of other people these
are just normal human beings their
resiliency their capability what they
can do what they what they stand for
their own for
- is usually far lower than that of
superheroes and that's one of the things
to understand is this is what makes this
kind of cool it's despite the fact that
anniversary flew through his head and
essentially you know kind of
incapacitated even if only you know even
temporarily this physical form of sumo
Korath sumo graph doesn't really care
he's just kinda like as I grow stronger
I will become more powerful and I will
devour all of you he's just kind of
blowing everybody off because of Shu
McGrath right that's the kind of power
that we're discussing here is one of
these things because I'm really kind of
trying to drive home in terms of how
powerful this guy is cuz we don't really
see him all too often now we do have a
beyond Omega level video where we do
talk about all the power of Shu McGrath
what he can do how capable he is but the
next thing that really comes in here is
when you basically have spider hero who
starts talking to Power Man and remember
Power Man has the ability it was kind of
the new iteration of Luke Cage kind of
but not really um he can use his visor
to essentially tap into the Chi energy
of the world around him and that's one
of the things that like spider hero
comes up and this is one of these is why
I asked you guys know who this guy is
because it's not spider-man or anybody
associated with the spider-man mythos
really he's a pretty cool character but
he offers these kind of words of wisdom
to to Power Man in saying everything in
this world has a kind of energy to it it
has Chi essentially you can tap into
that no it doesn't mean he can like turn
on a turn a tea pot into a into a cat
right it doesn't really work that way
but it's one of these things were it's
like basically what you can do is you
can tap into all this energy starting
from your home your comfort zone and
you're working your way out throughout
the entirety of the city even though
even the world if you chose to your job
is to tap into all that energy and it
basically take all that energy and
coalesce it into a singular ball and
then when he does that it's channeling
it directly into white tiger and so in
effect it's like when Goku absorbed a
spirit bomb it's really what it is right
this guy makes the spirit bomb out of
the city of New York but as basically
what's happening is he's channeling all
this energy and in a lot of ways pulling
on it on now I was not really pulling on
the life energy of other people in the
sense that like they're getting weaker
and they're dying but it is one of these
things where it's like okay like he's
pulling a sort of energy source it kind
of permeates out there and then passing
it on the white tiger who in turn uses
her ability to tap into the tiger god
and then basically channels all that
power expands on it and then the tiger
god destroys the physical form of Shu
McGrath and that's where things really
kind of begin to wrap up right because
it's kinda like okay with this physical
form of Shu begorrah basically being
assaulted where it initially goes back
to basically start a recon
Tooting itself again that's when
spectrum jumps in and whether powers
having been bolstered with the aid of
blue marble she's able to use her
manipulation over the entirety of the
electromagnetic spectrum and then wipe
out Shu McGrath in his physical form and
what it does is it Rico's as the portal
right the portal shuts back down and Shu
McGrath is essentially stayed once again
from being able to invade the the
entirety of the the main Marvel Universe
right because again if this if this
hadn't worked and this is kind of a big
gambit miss why is such a big deal
because if they had failed and this is
the one thing you have to think about if
the Mighty Avengers had failed and they
had not defeated Shu McGrath's at the
end of infinity like Shu McGrath would
have destroyed Thanos sure McGrath were
to destroy the the coulomb city and what
cuz remember the Infinity stones are
gone at this point they've been they've
been destroyed right we know that from
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers of New
Avengers there are no more Infinity
stones the cosmic cubes are basically
null and void now because the beyonders
are essentially in the main Maori
universe they shut down access to
anybody being able to access the beyond
versa there really are no cosmic cubes
going around anymore
but it's one of these things where it's
like when this goes on you know when
this witness goes down like had they
failed the Avengers would have arrived
back to earth to a world dominated by
Shu McGrath who would have been
expanding his sphere of influence
through the solar system and into the
galaxy and into the universe and there
would have been anything anybody could
have done to stop it no cosmic entities
no nothing right the universe would have
just fallen ^ xu mcgrath and the best
thing any of the superheroes could do is
just run and flee for their lives
that's basically it but from there with
the defeat of Shu McGrath that's
incredibly powerful character The Mighty
Avengers formation is solidified right
spectrum spider hero white tiger Power
Man blue Marvel and the superior
spider-man Doctor Octopus that's what
we're looking at now right that's the
team that we have assembled but but
Mighty Avengers was too cool right it
was a really really really cool team it
was really really cool line of stories
for a little while as short-lived as it
was it was a great line of stories but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here too comments explained and make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]